hello everybody hope they are good today
is Monday a new trading week and this
morning I woke up very happy because you
guys know that every Sunday night for
the past year and a half or so I post a
bit concerned update to try to prepare
ourselves for the week ahead and we
usually go through the liquidation heat
Maps we also go through other charts
such as for example literal index the
SMP the deals sometimes
and we try to understand what could
possibly going on for Bitcoin and I woke
up with this morning
the first thing that I did was uh to
check the telegram and also to check the
trading view I will actually trading
view ISO that the rejection is playing
out now if you go this is the chart from
yesterday okay
I guess most of you follow me on Twitter
so you probably saw this chart last
night but
you can see here how we had this weekend
rainster okay that's your weekend range
and we were expecting a false move up
above the fifth TMA in the four hour and
also in the one hour time frame and then
in the next candle close below it
because I know some people were possibly
waiting for the retrace of support and
you know what these guys do they said
limited buy orders at the 50 EMA retrace
okay so that's why in my opinion
and in my head was hang on
we could see a false move up
above the 50ma and then a share will
reverse it back down and go straight
away for the liquidations at 26 100.
okay and then from there we can go to
this liquidity pool of 27 000. that's a
massive red candle
and that's an imbalance in the chart
okay so you can see how my logic was
pretty simple
um I mean it's got logical I think you
can see how they did the Australia way
after I posted that tweet further modes
I said 20 within the next 24 hours well
I think it happened within the next two
hours but you can see that Force move up
pretty much even to to this target here
and then the richest dog back down
straight away and they go towards the
regulations of 26 100 as the song that
we are right now at okay now what is
interesting to me is this
they hit exactly 26
000.0 that is not coincidence that is
telling you
that that's a move from the market maker
because the market maker has enough
volume enough money enough liquidity to
move price at their will
and whatever they want so they're gonna
target round numbers and this happens
all the time that's why it's good to pay
attention to the round numbers okay
so what do we have in front of us I mean
um the first two moves have happened
first move up then the drop towards the
liquidations and that is why even if
today is Monday I'm not considering this
the first move because the liquidations
were already here so Doug was a Target
okay that's not force move that was a
natural move
to just hit some liquidations and that's
what I was telling you yesterday that I
was expecting this level to get hit and
for that I needed a justification of a
false move up
and there it is because the market maker
likes to trick the little Trader right
at the start of of the week and that can
be Sunday evening or uh of Monday London
maybe New York in in Monday okay so it
usually happens between Sunday Ephraim
and Monday
then go back down all the way to hit
this liquidations okay so now
this projection here
for the Sunday update he's telling us
that we could see now here a bottom and
then a reversal back up
towards this liquidity pool okay that is
the original uh projection nevertheless
uh this has happened so my job right now
is to look at the chart
and try to see if this is still valid
and if I can defend it enough to put
some bits here
okay because I like to usually put my
money after I see the reaction from the
scandals all right so right now I can
tell you I'm not in a long position
right now okay but I'm trying to prepare
myself ahead for that potential position
so
um that's the that's the thing now if
we're in the one hour time frame and the
thing that catches my attention
uh is that we also have here a couple of
liquidity pools you got that one there
you also go one another one there okay
so you also have a couple of smaller
liquidity pools to the upside okay
potential imbalances to get recovered
later this week that's what it means to
me and also
if you are honest
we can already start to see here how we
are forming some kind of a bottom okay
week week now you come back to this week
you are holding here
this could be a reversal okay now to
certainly understand this move better
let's go into lower time frame 15
minutes time frame okay and you can see
how this could turn out to be a
potential free tops button first up
second top three top one two three
reversal
is a possibility
I mean why not guys all right why not if
you reverse the chart
I mean if you reverse a chart sometimes
it can help you guys to see
to see more book it's true that we could
see another stop hunt okay
we could see one more stop on here
or even towards digital line digital
line is the range loss of this current
range so if you go like this you'll be
able to see the range better okay that's
your range size
that's your range lows okay and if you
follow that yellow line it takes you
there
okay so you can see how it takes you
there so
in my opinion
I just think we're gonna see a reversal
okay could we drop two hundred dollars
lower
before the reversal happens
it's possible guys it's possible so
essentially what I'm trying to see what
I'm trying to say here is that this one
here
it's
a potential reversal Zone
with the possibility
of a stophunt
to watch this Zone
okay and if you continue dropping lower
instead then I believe we'll see the
reversal here
I personally don't see
price going low I mean again you have
sorry you have here this massive
liquidity pool
but I have the feeling that we're only
gonna go here
once the market maker once decides to
take this liquidity over here dieting
the three months time frame liquidation
hit them up so that's why I'm not
targeting for a reversal in this
liquidity pool because I don't think
life price comes towards this liquidity
pool it will potentially break lower
go to twenty three thousand four hundred
or so and that's where there are of
liquidation so I'm looking for a
reversal in during this week to happen
either in this one here this blue box or
we could still see
this is top hunt
uh towards this week okay I'm not going
to be a perfect entry but if we see a
stop from the price Consolidated let me
remove all of this because it's a mess
right now so you can see that clearly
okay so again potential reversal soon
they have their one two three tops
button could be a potential reversal we
could still see
a stop on towards this week
okay
but if price goes to fill this week
fully okay and it doesn't reverse so if
we just consolidate here that's a bad
sign and that is telling you that price
is gonna head lower towards this zero
line okay so I want you to pay attention
to this
now how can you trade this
I'm gonna go through the green so hit
the maps and everything but so far what
I can see is that a good it doesn't seem
like a bad idea to me to open a small
position here
okay and then I'm not telling you to go
you know with a hundred percent of your
size and then you need to go maybe with
a 25 of your size
okay then you can compound if if that's
the perfect entry in that case then you
can comp that entry for example with
this retest here of that 50ma okay then
you can compile that an open position a
better entry all right bro
I don't think that it would it doesn't
seem to me like a bad idea to open a
small position here maybe 25 30 then if
price decides to go lower then
I'll be watching the reaction here
at this week okay because if you see a
bounce here
then that'll be your second entry but if
price goes all the way here and then
consolidates then you close this
position because price is likely to go
towards the range lows okay so that it
is three potential entries clear
invalidations with all of them do you
know how to compound so what I'm looking
is to possibly operate a small position
here then say if price decides to go
lower towards this week if so this
deviation compound there okay operating
position because then I believe that
we'll see a reversal from there but if
you come here and there is no bounce
there is no reaction and there is only
consolidation then you don't open here
do close here and price goes to the Rain
slows and then here is when you can
start to look again for new Longs okay
so that is what it's in my mind okay
that's how you must think
as a Trader first you have to try to
figure out the direction of the move
now I think it's gonna be to the upside
okay that's what I'm looking for Longs
now and then once you thought about the
direction then you have to think about
the entries and I see entries in plural
because as soon as you think about one
entry you must think about the valuation
like what the possibility of the next
move could be and of course there is a
possibility of a stophunt that could be
another entry to compound that entry
okay or if there is consolidation here
that evaluates both trades both entries
and then you're gonna be looking for an
entry in this zone so I want this to be
clear guys
okay because this is the only way to
make money here you have to think in
terms of probabilities
and always
with clear invalidations
and I know that it might be difficult
for some of you that don't have the the
whole day and you don't have the full
time to look at the charts and see the
behavior of the candlesticks and
everything because maybe you are working
and you have you know to look after some
family
but in my case here at home in front of
my screen
the way that I trade is by looking at
the reaction from the market in key
zones
that I marked in the chart
okay I very rarely set limit orders I
prefer watching the reaction from the
chart from the candlesticks and then
execute the traits accordingly and
that's something I think that if you
have the chance you have the time
is what I make you more profitable over
time because otherwise what you would
have done yesterday
in the one hour time frame for example
was to set
a buy order here
that's what you have done okay you could
use in the spike up and then say okay
to see if there is continuation to the
upside and then you would have been
wrecked
okay otherwise if you are waiting for
this candle to close to consider back
handle closed
below the 50ma and that you have a huge
quick below it so you know that you know
the next candle is very likely that it
goes and field and feels that week same
as here huge week here what do you think
is going to happen next well the market
is going to go towards that week
so that's what I mean guys
the market will give you opportunities
okay you don't have to create those
opportunities the market creates them
for you to exploit them
but you can only explore with them with
patience and knowing what you want to
send the chart so for example yesterday
of course it helped me to understand
with the Sunday update that I was very
likely to see a false move to the sun I
mean guys if you mark this you can see
that that's pretty much what I marked
okay so I knew exactly the zone
what I wanted to see a first move so
when I saw that push up then I thought
okay guys life potentially the force
move we're looking for
okay so that's what I mean
in in terms of becoming a better Trader
I would suggest
that you mark the songs of interest in
the charter source of liquidity the
imbalances call it as you want
and then trade with the reaction of
those counter sticks
okay A little Master Class there for you
now uh enough blah blah blah let's go to
high blood Capital let's see what is
going on there guys what's going on with
hablo Capital let's have a look
all right liquidation levels first did
you guys know the rules I would even
have to say it anymore liquidation
levels first and the heat map all right
so what can we see here guys we can see
that we have five million dollars worth
of liquidations now you might think hang
on
that is the same as last week as on
Thursday or Friday and I'll tell you yes
because over the weekend we have you
know sideways move up down up down up
down weeks there weeks over there and
then stop closing a lot of liquidations
there are a lot of positions okay so
that's why it went all the way to two
billion dollars from five
well it actually even going to see
though to be honest that was that from
yesterday's done but I went to zero it
usually goes to Syrian over the weekends
and now what you can see is that we have
five billion dollars worth of short
liquidation at risk
which um to be honest is not something
uh very crazy you usually see uh a
strong signals of reversals with Delta
when it's higher again that doesn't mean
that we could see a reverse we cannot
assume that because there are five
billion dollars worth of short
liquidation so we're gonna see a
reversal okay this is Confluence but I
cannot justify
because when you can justify a reversal
straight away is when this is over 10
billion dollars usually okay at least
according to my uh
um to what I've been saying for the past
year year and a half with this all right
so what can we see in the liquidation
level well if we look at the spikes at
the right of the chart I mean this is
spikes okay
the question is where do you see more
spikes guys do you see them to the
upside or to the downside
I think the answer is clear here of
course to the upside right check this
out okay
you go here
188 million dollars worth of short
liquidations at 26 300 another spec here
twenty six thousand five hundred another
Spike here twenty six thousand eight
hundred twenty seven thousand one
hundred twenty seven thousand three
hundred so clearly the liquidations are
to the upside
if you look to the downside there is
only one zone
where there are some liquidations and is
this is Spike over here that it takes
you to 25
840. dies that range lows so that's what
I'm telling you is there a possibility
that we go to the range lows
it is all right now I want to see a
reversal before we go to the range lows
that's why I'm playing with the D of the
for example the three tops pattern or
the stop hunt Okay and then if that gets
invalidated then you know yes we can
drop another 200 which is isn't much to
be honest and go towards the range loss
okay well maybe there we could see a
reversal
okay so that is how I look at the
liquidation levels now if you go to the
recreational heat Maps
let's start with the 12 hours time frame
we've seen a drop so it's likely that
the liquidations are to the upside
there you go whoa 26575
which is quite far away from here to
again it's 500 away so that's an
interesting Zone
twenty seven thousand one hundred
so this chart I mean is clearly telling
you that the liquidity is to the upside
but again it could be because we've seen
that drop seven days time frame this
time frame is even more interesting
because
um on Saturday I posted also this tweet
I was telling you you know it seems that
we are going to consolidate over the
weekend between these two liquidation
levels and then next week we can see
them tagging at least one of them so I'm
going to check this out consolidation
here until Sunday and then today on
Monday they drop and hit these
liquidations because if you see with
this consolidation over here see the
behavior of that yellow bar it gets
brighter and brighter and brighter
because what the market making is trying
to do here is to induce traders to open
Longs that's for example why you saw
yesterday the first moved to the upside
the start of the week because as it's
the start of the week and you know you
see an aggressive move it could be to
the upset to the dancer the little
Trader is nothing okay then this week is
going to be green or this week is going
to be red
so that is why we usually have Force
moves at the start of the week right
so thus will happen the liquidations are
26 100 increased you see the drop they
get hit and by looking at this chart you
can see that there are still some
liquidations all the way at 27 600 all
right
again this chart telling you the
liquidity downside is taken and the
remaining liquidities to the upside one
month time frame
this time frame is screaming out of us
guys
28 300 range highs of course you also
have some liquidity at twenty four
thousand eight hundred but this yellow
bar has been there for quite some time
keeps getting brighter
could we assumed that we can hit the
next
why not guys okay
um in the next time frame three months
time frame this is the only time frame
that so far has been telling us the
liquidity is to the downside okay and
this is a time frame that we've been
analyzing for the past
I don't know guys
or month something crazy okay and a
yearly started when we saw this week
towards this Zone
we were consolidating and the liquidity
here kept increasing so that is quite
normal at the end you are here inside a
range so you can go up down up down hope
again who knows all right and then
eventually and this can take several
weeks maybe a month maybe two months
nobody knows because this is three
months time from this is higher time
frame then I believe that eventually
we'll see the drop towards the sun okay
and that's what you have to understand
you know
short-term day trading that's what we do
midterm for swing trades and high time
frame like this you mean to sport bigger
moves so uh let's go to the Chart let's
try to make some sense of what we've
seen here because I know that there is a
lot of information so let's try to
summarize it into the chart back in
Bitcoin and I can possibly understand
from the liquidation levels is that
you've hit the liquidity here addition
a 26 100 the liquid is taken again
you can see a reversal here a potential
stopping there and if there is
consolidation here and no advantages
straight away with a stop hunting
slows okay guys
for day trading now
as a day trader I I think by looking at
those hit maps that the liquidity is to
the upside so one favorite launch
towards that sun okay that's in terms of
a day trader now you go to the Daily
time frame guys and for a swing Trader
you'll be looking at different things
because you'll be looking at the one
month time frame and you'll be saying
that there is a lot of liquidity at 28
300. so how can you trade this well
you'll need to see a move up above the
50ma in the daily time frame okay
if you close above that time frame test
your support that also pretty much
matches with the weekly timeframe you
can see there okay
let me remove this
you can see how it matches it's a 26700
700 so if you can see
a recovery or a reclaim of the weekly
and the daily 50ma dies when you can
open longs
okay towards the rain size and that's
when you can short towards 23 400.
okay
now if you are a holder then you are
looking for buy zones one can be 23 500.
Bo
in my opinion there is a chance that we
keep going lower for one simple reason
first of all is because you'll be
recovering retracing this liquidity pool
here okay so why not recover the whole
thing
and second because you have this week
here it's a huge week right below it and
that takes you the full week to 29 500
but the 50 of the week is exactly at
twenty thousand seven hundred
okay so as a minimum Target for hold in
my opinion as long as we stay below the
quickly and the daily 50ma
that is gonna be a force driving us to
the downside and as a holder
this one here is going to be the next
Target twenty thousand seven hundred
okay and I've been saying this for I
don't know how long guys we've been
hearing the same thing for ages but I
keep trying to remind you because I know
that there are new people and also
because I know that some of us uh need
that they continuous remind us uh
something so uh that's my opinion guys
in case you have any doubts okay so in
terms of day trading guys very clear go
to the 15 minutes time frame see what it
goes on here
open New York opens in three hours okay
let's see how London finishes the
session Bo if we hold in this Zone one
two three hits to the downside potential
Phillips pattern and reversal back up
okay otherwise another scenario is
a stop hunt in the New York session
towards this week here
and then you want to see
a strong reaction that's what you can
compound okay and then you want to see
the reversal over the next two three
days
um I believe okay now if you see this is
a stop hunt
consolidation here then
you know we are not opening position
here and we are closing this one here
because price will likely go to the
right slow so
um pretty simple uh trading idea wait
for the New York session
and watch the candlesticks okay what's
the behavior
are those two key zones okay so that
would be
this one over here
that's a key level and then
this one here and uh if it's a stop
front is likely that you don't only hit
it but also it's very likely that you
even sweep the lows okay something like
this so if you see this that's when you
can compound this entry okay and you can
go higher but if you see
that you sweep the lows but you stay
below this low so you're consolidating
here
and you're not seeing a clear bounce a
clear reaction then close this trade
don't open here again because price is
going to go to the Rain slows I want
this to be very clear because that is
what I'm basically going to be doing
today okay so guys
thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you soon